- Well you seem pretty laid back.
Are you laid back?
Are you kinda the strict one?
- Like of my parents?
- I'm definitely strict.
- I am too.
- Yeah, I was raised by a very--
- Me too.
- Strong single mother whose.
- Yeah, German and yeah so.
- Greek, but yeah.
- It's tough because now I can provide.
At one point it was extremely challenging.
- Yeah.
- It was hard for my mother so.
I'm really stoked like my first skateboard
I like pride and joy--
- My first keyboard.
- Now I give everything.
I'm like what do you want?
But at the same time (grunts)
- I know, that's the thing my husband
and I talk about we grew
up with like nothing
and when you have kids you're like
how do I gauge this?
Like what's proper?
I know that's that struggle.
But your daughter Lola, she's 12 right?
- Yeah.
- She's 12 and did she start dating yet?
'Or 'cause that's young--
- No!
(laughs)
(audience laugh)
No!
Lola is a saint.
She is gonna be a nun.
- She is gonna get married at 30.
- Lola is a nun, she is a saint.
- No I'm just saying.
- No!
- Can I tell you that I have it way worse?
My daughter keeps coming home.
Some boy named Bo I'm gonna have to beat.
(audience laugh)
'Cause like yeah she's
five man, I'm screwed.
Yeah five.
- You're screwed, yeah.
- Is she not into boys yet?
Is she still like, eh?
- Yeah, no.
- Okay.
- But I feel sorry for,
I mean it's gonna be fun
when the boy does arrive.
- Oh my god.
- You know what I mean?
(both laugh)
- All those weapons, you know what I mean?
- Just wear a lot of flannel.
And just grunt.
Don't say anything.
(grunts)
Let's just say grunt at 'em.
(audience laughs)
Anyway what do your kids
think of you (both laugh)
as Aquaman though really?
When they saw the movie was
that kinda cool for them?
'Cause they're so young and
really getting into that.
- It was perfect, I mean they
grew up with Justice League.
So they got to wear the tiara.
He was obsessed with Batman,
Wolfie was so he gets to wear everything
and be in the Batmobile.
Yeah, and the first time I saw it,
I actually waited 'cause I
wanted to see it with my babies.
And so we went to the premier
and saw it together.
- That's exciting!
- Wolfie's extremely emotional.
So when I would get hurt or get beat up,
he'd be like crying
and I'd be like buddy papa's right here,
yeah know what I mean?
But we don't have t.v.
We don't have phones or any of that stuff.
- Really?
That's good.
- Yeah just 'cause their
little imaginations
are growing and it's
like let them have that.
They have the rest of their
life watch all this stuff.
- I agree.
You're a good dad, okay.